In this section, we're going to just briefly cover
a few different features and tools that
are available to you that really tie intrinsically
to Sequencer, building out these shots,
or creating these really beautiful cinematic
experiences.
So one of the things that, and this has
been in the engine for quite a while, is Take Recorder.
Now, Take Recorder allows you to control actors or record
motion for them.
As an example, so here we have two meerkats on screen,
and you'll see inside of Take Recorder
that we have both of these actors present.
So let's say that we're creating this,
I don't know, a dialogue between the two meerkats.
They're talking to each other.
They're moving.
And I'm using a motion capture suit to control them,
basically puppet them in engine.
But it's only me, lonely me, doing this recording.
So how can I do both actors without having to have two suits?
We use a Take Recorder for that.
So with this little toggle here,
I can turn on and off recording that particular actor.
So I could have the first meerkat turned on,
hit my record button, it will do a countdown,
and then it will start recording to a sequence
all of the animations that it's recording
from my motion capture.
I can hit stop.
It'll record all that information.
I will then deactivate the first one,
which I was just controlling, activate the second one,
hit my Take Record.
It will go ahead and automatically advance to another.
I'll record the secondary meerkat,
and then I can simply squish all these together
in a separate sequence.
And now I have both actors
interacting and working together.
So again, that's just one example of it,
but Take Recorder is just a great way
to rapidly record information
from some kind of live source,
whether that's a virtual camera, controlling actors,
even using controller input as well.
All of those things can be controlled
and recorded directly through Take Recorder.
We talked about this in one of the previous videos
about Live Link Face, as well as MetaHuman Animator.
This is a phenomenal tool.
It essentially allows you to take an iOS device
and record basically anything,
whether it's your facial animation
or potentially moving your body
or using it as a camera.
All of this is completely markerless,
meaning that you can, just as an example here,
point the iOS device at your face,
and you can instantly start recording facial animations
in the editor.
Now this one does require Live Link Face turned on
and the app installed on your device.
But again, these are 100% completely free
and you can do that.
We also talked too about our VCAM,
that we can use the same crosstalk interface
behind the scenes, Live Link,
to control a virtual camera within
the actual editor itself.
And of course, record that information to a sequence.
So we can do that through Live Link VCAM,
Unreal Remote, both of these are completely free.
Now, if you're watching this video,
I do recommend using the hot pink one,
which is the Live Link VCAM,
will allow you to connect through that.
That is the more up to date one, but I digress.
So with it too, one of the pro tips I recommend is
if you are considering using a virtual camera
with a iOS device,
a very handy thing to get you more realistic
or more natural feeling camera work is,
you know, the iPad by itself is a fairly light device.
And so it's gonna translate very subtle movements
of your hand or your body moving a lot more
than if it had some weight.
There's various different companies out there,
not gonna plug any of them,
but you can find essentially what are shoulder rigs
or camera rigs that will hold an iPad for you,
allowing you to put like extra weight on it,
to put it on your shoulder, to handle it.
That small addition to your workflow
is going to have very, very big implications
and a very big impact on the final look
of that camera movement.
So I highly recommend if you're gonna be using
a virtual camera, definitely get some different rigs
to hold the iPad, to add some weight,
and that will just make things feel more natural
to the user and hopefully require less
kind of post editing with the different key frames.
Another fun note, pro tip here,
is that you can actually use a Nintendo Switch controller
with iOS 16 or later, which is really great
because you can actually map these camera controls
like zooming in, zooming out, your f-stop,
translation, et cetera, extremely handy
and extremely quick, especially when working
with take recorder to quickly do some camera movements,
reshoot it with almost little to no downtime.
And then as a note too,
without shamelessly plugging iOS devices,
I will say this, that they are more widely supported
and that is a testament to Apple's hardware
in that it's just the forward facing cameras,
the depth sensors, the gyroscopes as well,
are very, very high quality and it's one of the reasons
why you'll find like the V cam as well as Live Link,
why they just work a little bit better with Apple.
However, there is an Android device out there,
but my recommendation is if you're gonna be using
this workflow with a mobile device,
again, if you're capturing your face
or you're capturing a V cam,
I would highly recommend using an Apple device
over an Android, just because again,
you'll get a higher quality output
and there's more supported features,
but just know that the virtual app by Owl Studio
does work with Live Link with a V cam, so it's there,
but it is also not a free plugin anymore,
it is now $80, so keep that in mind.
Another really great tool is Epos,
which actually comes from Praxinos,
they've got the Epos in Iliad as well.
And this is a great tool that allows you
to essentially do storyboarding directly
within Sequencer, in fact, you can create this,
I'll just say piece of content for lack of better terms,
the container for Epos, and it'll actually allow you
to storyboard on the actual sequence itself,
see playbacks, this is amazing for creating animatics
or even doing some editing, you can even do blending
of 2D, so what you're actually gonna be doing in Epos,
some of these 2D elements with the actual scene itself,
which is just great, so this is a phenomenal tool to use,
it is free to use, it's on the Unreal Engine Marketplace,
again, Epos and Iliad are the two tools for that.
And then here's Iliad as well, which again,
allows you to do some traditional texture painting,
great resources from them.